- [Voiceover] "Click on
the graph below to draw
"a right triangle with right angle
"at x equals eight, y equals six,
"and hypotenuse extending
from zero comma 14
"to negative 10 comma negative 12."
Well, looks like they've
given us the three vertices
of the triangle so we
could just plot them.
So let's just, it says,
"Click to add vertices."
So let's do that.
We have one at eight comma six,
x equals eight, y is equal to six.
Then we have one at zero comma 14.
So x equals zero, y is equal to 14
and it drew the line there.
And then we go from that point
to negative 10 comma negative 12.
Negative 10, wrong side,
x is negative 10,
y is negative 12.
So we go to that point right over there
and then we can just
connect everything back
by going to our original point
and there we have it.
It even drew the nice right
angle right over there.
There we have it.
We have our right triangle.
We'd really just have to plot the points
in order actually.
Any order would have worked
because there's only three points here.
So yeah, that was it.